hello everyone I've shown you three
games from the champions showdown and
all three games were played between
Magnus Carlsen and ding leerin and I'm
very surprised none we've suggested any
games from the other matches so I
decided to show you one game it was
played between Fabiano Caruana and
alexander grease joke and well the
result is quite interesting in their
match as like Carlson and Engler and
they they both play the four matches
like four mini matches someone was at
the first match was four games of
30-minute chess then I believe it was
six games of 20-minute chest then eight
games of 10-minute chess and twelve
games of 5-minute chest and in the first
section in the 30-minute chess the
result was two to two in the 20-minute
section the result was three and a half
to two and a half degree strokes favour
and in the 10-minute section the result
was four to four so in the first three
sections alexander grace took actually
took the lead but then something very
unexpected happened well an expected to
me i thought of grace chuck would shine
in any section it would be in the blade
section i mean after all he is quite a
blitz player and he was the the world
blitz champion but unexpectedly Caruana
took this section with eight and a half
to three and a half so and in the end
winning the match but the game i decided
to show it was from the 10-minute
section it's quite an interesting game a
really tactical game both players really
go all out so I do hope you enjoy it
Corona has the white pieces and he plays
efore we had e5 Knight to f3 knight c6
Bishop to b5 Knight to f6 d3 now Bishop
to c5 and it's interest interesting this
Bishop to c5 line of the Berlin seems to
be becoming a usual thing in big
tournaments and player would the black
pieces seems to be achieving some nice
victories with this line Knight to c3
great job castles now Bishop captures on
c6 d captors on c6 and Knight to e2
rook to e8 h 397 may be preparing f5 g4
is played Bishop to b4 check and now
Khurana plays the very interesting King
to f1 he doesn't go for c3 that's
interesting he goes for a king to f1 and
now this bishop does look funny on
before so ok no problems Greece Turkey
mediately plays a bishop back to f8
Knight G 3
now this Knight has some really nice
outpost on f5 and h5 knife to c5 and
Bishop to e3 f6 Knight to f5 and we have
a knight the e6 it seems like a good
idea since this light square bishop
isn't really doing anything to capture
this powerful Knight on f5 but if you
capture it after G captures on f5 you
opened up the G file for for this rook
on h1 and also now white is controlling
the e6 square which which will be a good
square for this night for example Knight
should jump to e6 and then he can choose
to go either d4 or f4 so instead after
Knight to f5 Drishti goes for night to
e6 immediately Rock to g1 King h8
getting the King out of the rooks away
and now h4 g5 here could be a bit
premature as black could just ignore
this and push g6 to kick away the night
selector King h8 h 4 was played now g6
with an attack on the knight Knight to
h6 Queen to e7 Queen d2 c5 it's a it's a
nice move it really secures the d4
square for the knight is preparing b6
and the bishop will obviously be
developed on b 7r up to g3 b6 now
preparing to develop the light square
Bishop King g2 preparing to get the
other rook into the game
Bishop to b7 and our rook to h1 rook a
to d8 developing and the h5 now Bishop
captures on h6 and here the the expected
response would be Bishop captures on h6
of course
but Khurana goes 4-h captures on g6 to
open up the H file and immediately go
for the attack here we have Bishop
captures on e3 and what do you do here
well you can't capture D H pawn with the
rook to win the Queen because after you
capture the Queen will capture it
there's no more chicks and then you will
lose your queen on D 2 so f captures on
e3 and now Knight to f8 to protect the
h7 pawn we have G fine now Knight
captures on g6g captures on f6 would
attempt on the Queen Queen captures and
Knight to g5 again kuranes threatening
to capture on h7 so rook to e7 defending
rook to f1 now with a temple on the
Queen Queen to g7 and rock back to h1
now again threatening to capture on h7
Queen to g8 now the rook is again
protecting in the h7 pawn queen 2 e 2
preparing Queen to h5 c4 now breaking
open the center rook the rook to h6
first now Queen to h5 will be more
powerful C captures on d3 seek after
Sundy 3 and rook to d6 and the corona
now now goes for it Queen to h5 he
doesn't mind giving up the d3 pawn
because it seems like it's a it's a
poisonous pawn you know white white does
have a lot of pieces surrounding the
black king but the pawn really isn't
poisonous and the glistrup smells this
and captures it rook captures and v3 and
it's interesting what do you do here
there's there is an interesting line you
know some of you might think that Knight
captures on h7 is winning for white for
example rook captures and then rook
captures on g6 and now black is getting
either checkmated or he loses the Queen
at the problem with this is after you
play Knight captures on h7 black doesn't
recapture the knight black plays Bishop
captures on e4 with check and after you
move the King the simple rook captures
on h7 now is completely winning for
black because the bishop is now
protecting the knight on g6 and there
no capture Sanji six anymore so after
Rick after sandy three karana doesn't
really have a move here he has to wait
in g1 getting the King away from this
Bishop to b4 check rook to d6 rook to g2
now Rock to g7 we have key Queen to g4
Knight to f8 now the knight is pinned it
can't move rook to h5 protecting the
night rook D to g6 now Greece Chuck is
owning that G file Queen to a5 we are
Knight to d7 a king - h1 getting the
King away from any checks if the roof
does capture on g2 Knight to f6 with an
attack on the rook we have rope to h4
and now Knight captures on e4 and what
do you play here nothing really for you
to play you can't capture the night if
you capture it you you lose the rook
captures on g2 and White has no more
moves so after night captors on e4
Corona tried one last idea he played
Knight captures on h7 hoping that Greece
chip will capture the rook on g2 and
then Caruana will have some discoveries
but unfortunately in Greece joke played
night the g3 would check and in this
position
Fabiano Khurana resigning the game the
king is in check the Queen is forked you
can't capture the night because it's
pinned from the bishop on b7 so the
black/white it really doesn't have any
moves to play here if you play something
like Queen g1 after Knight captures on
f5 yes you do have some discoveries but
none of the discoveries really work
whatever you're playing I do if I check
simply Knight captures rook and it's
game over
so yeah a great game by Alexander Greece
shook and a great performance against
Fabiano Caruana and almost 2800 player I
believe he is twenty seven hundred and
ninety-seven at this moment or something
you know winning in the first three
sections against a guy like that is
quite impressive and like I said it it
took me by surprise that Cara wanna
managed to win eight and a half to three
and a half in the bullet section
but that's just you know think things
happen so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here and one more thing
I'm really running out of quotes to put
on top of my board so if any of you have
any interesting quotes you know maybe
maybe that only exists in your country
or maybe they're not very famous you
know feel free to share I will share
them with everyone so yeah thank you for
watching and I will see you soon